hello everyone and welcome to how so far
as I'm sorry I'm Jess um and today I was
like it's made your attic screams it's
it's also video game history month here
at GameSpot those are two very different
directions we just went running that
both important they are both important
specially to us game as a game spot so
to celebrate that we're going a bit rich
excuse me so today we are revisiting one
of my favorite horror games yeah time
and I do believe a lot of people have
noted this as well that is their
favorite and that is Resident Evil 2 if
you want to pick this up I got this from
the PSN store at least he kept his yeah
yeah so the cooling brothers game is you
can actually there's two parts to this
story is just one destitute and you can
actually play as one of either character
but you get different sides of the story
so if you played this one with Claire
and then you switch like disc one to lay
on it you'll be playing the same story
but different size cuz they better split
up
yeah
Oh God
no one notices on me the bag always
check the backseat good lord
I'm playing Michael Bay Resident Evil so
watch this just what those lines Oh No
all right we're off to a good start
don't get eaten by a zombie she does run
quick good running play damn I didn't
time that properly fools
what do you mean fools now after that
way running from this smile wait watch
this she's gonna walk up the stairs
normally oh my good man she's gonna go
back to being injured again oh she just
used the energy that she had to get you
up the stairs quickly oh my god is
brutal Oh oh my god what she's being
like accosted
oh my god that's the thing that happens
that close
oh you kicked a head off oh my god oh
god we have to see that scene again Jim
yeah we do shoot faster though sorry
about that babe see Canadian let's not
blame Canadian please not please how the
hell did I play this is a kid yeah oh
you [ __ ] bringing the pain oh yeah it's
right oh nice
I never call them zombies so way
something else guys daebak there's like
no you must sound like you sound that
you're dying more time are you okay are
you jerking he's bleeding from his chest
she's so insensitive he's gonna cry I'm
Elsa madness and said I missed out on an
easy paycheck when they were hiring
anyone to be boys it's all the same
these days back then it was easy to get
into worse he has no skin
wow that's yeah even like in an old
thing that's yeah
we'll need to watch him push push with
your face 1990 is calling the packs now
go to dodge the blink I'd say oh I've
got all my god you're facing and your
chest is getting attacked holy crap oh
good touch oh jeez it runs fast oh god
it's so quick now I just have to remove
the way we use this key this is my feels
oh this could be a final words love I
think I need some sorry darling babe
sure no you should help it
I'm concerned that no one seems to care
that there's a little girl running
around by herself
what are you safe she win
is fine the best she can be yep fine
this is it look for the girl and the guy
it says good uh because women are always
like I'm fine I'm fine
and it says fine but she's really not
fine at all her chicks right oh god
what's that sound oh Jesus Christ oh my
god he came like streaming down the
hallway oh let's jump I remember oh it's
the bookcases yes yeah I know there are
panels on the other side we can move far
left one might need to move to the right
yeah that's right yeah genius well done
I'm fine I contribute man this game
still looks all right for something
that's like
no Monty a writer oh jeez
you want this oh that was something in
the corner Oh cuz she looks with it yeah
yeah oh my goodness yeah you're so chic
oh my god oh [ __ ]
holy crap oh my god nothing is wrong
what how can you say that right now
nothing is wrong with this soda machine
soda machine is fine we need not worry
all these zombies look the same oh my
god you can't just say that was on me
look the same
zombies have rights too you know they
don't dream them Kemp boom
as usual listen what you thought about
the stream in the comments in the chat
or on Twitter with the HOH and live
hashtag you can join the conversation if
you don't have a twitch account we do
read all the tweets and the comments so
let us know what you thought and as
always if you want us to play a specific
game let us know through all those
channels it is retro gaming month so
anything like that can I trust as a
retro game on how Sapporo's we'll be
more than glad to check it out thank you